Time to dust off
an old crowdpleaser.
Aye, there.
Who has me potato?
Mick Face.
[laughter]
♪ I drink all night ♪
♪ I drink all day ♪
♪ I punch me wife
the Irish way ♪
Huh!
♪ Go to the bar,
spend all our quid ♪
♪ My wife stays home
and has another kid ♪
♪ Got ginger hair,
I'm a Catholic ♪
♪ I'm a drunk
potato-loving dirty Mick ♪
♪ O Danny Boy,
the alcohol is calling ♪
♪ It's saying I'm a pissed
old Paddy snout ♪
♪ And we won't win
our pointless war with England ♪
♪ And no one wants us here
so we should just get out ♪
I don't know how
she manages to do it,
but Lillian is always
on the cutting edge of comedy.
[laughs]
♪ When God made me,
he was playing a trick ♪
♪ 'Cause I'm a drunk,
potato-loving ♪
♪ wife-beating, bar-fighting,
ginger-haired ♪
♪ disgusting dirty Mick ♪
Thank you.
[cheers and applause]
Judges.
(Dan)
Two tens and--oh, a zero,
from the esteemed gentleman
from Donegal.
Seemed to be a crowd-pleaser,
but we do need to be sensitive
to all the white races.
A zero?